shorter
no one trolls Kim Kardashian harder than
her eldest daughter Northwest having
kids is just there's no way to describe
it but it's a lot and on the latest
episode of the famous family's Hulu
series The Kardashians northie was back
at it throwing some subtle shade at her
mama you just gotta roll with it the
reality star's daughter was at Kim's
office for the skims icons campaign
shoot this is my daughter Dorothy
featuring Tyra Banks Heidi Klum
Alessandra Ambrosio and Candace
swedenpool you have no idea how iconic
this is you just have no idea it just
they were legendary they are legendary
Kim was geeking out over the A-list
Talent so when the ladies insisted that
Kim slip into some skims and join them
for a few snaps Kim jumped at the chance
I really wasn't planning on it but I'm
not gonna turn it down thank God I've
laser hair removaled everything from my
entire body so I don't have to worry
about like Did I Shave today or anything
like that
okay I'm in the campaign I'm about to do
a shoot with the icons Tyra Heidi
Candace Alexandra and cam what that's
when Northeast swooped in to Humble Kim
[Music]
but this is hardly the first time North
has proved she's Kim's biggest critic I
don't know how you're gonna top that who
could forget when she trolled her mom
last year for using a different voice
when she posts on social media okay I'm
gonna open it and show you guys
why do I talk different for what when I
do videos for my videos I'm the same
human being I don't talk different oh
and how about that time she interrupted
Kim while the mama for was trying to
show off some swag she received from
Olivia Rodrigo to promote the singer's
album sour cute as Olivia Rodrigo you
guys can't wait for her album you guys
know I love driver's license
look she sent a box of tissues
yeah she's straight up called came out
saying she doesn't listen to Olivia that
was like so inappropriate yes I do I
listen to it all the time and back in
2020 Kim's little girl totally crashed
her PSA about social distancing amid the
coronavirus pandemic hi everyone in
California it's Kim Kardashian West and
I just wanted to talk to you and
Northwest
I know that can you not jump on the bed
give me like two seconds to seriously do
this oh and let's not forget this
classic moment I'm hiding in the guest
room you guys I'm hiding in the guest
room because my kids
will not leave me alone hey that's me
North can I please just do my little
tutorial I I it's all I want to do is
one little fun thing for myself North's
personality is so big she even inspired
a super popular fan account Nori's black
book which was featured on the famous
family's hit reality show Keeping Up
with the Kardashians so I kind of just
started on Instagram whatever and then I
kind of built her personality off Kim's
how direct she is with all of you from
me Northwest she's right a thousand
times that's literally what she's like
no and that's truly who it is Ichi
caught up with the founder of the
account last year who dished on how the
whole thing came to be North was born
and you know they had the Babies R Us
line the Kardashians they put her in the
outfit and I remember saying can you
imagine how I'm upset North probably is
because she's probably like actually
we're in Chanel Balenciaga Supreme like
something else but I'm in this cheat
Babies R Us clothes and so like a light
bulb went off and I was like oh that's
it this is like the thing
foreign
[Music]